Okay, so let's go ahead and take a look at the landscape manage mode.
For this, it's actually best if we just jump into the engine.
So I'm going to go ahead and do that so we can take a look at the tools itself within
the context of the engine.
So if I open up my editor here, I've got an empty map essentially with a little bit of
light things that we can see what we're doing.
And I'm going to go to my landscape tool and just create a flat normal landscape.
You can see I've got it set up to 1009 by 1009, which is one of the recommended size
on the chart.
And let's go ahead and press create.
Now if I go to manage tab here, the manage tab essentially allows you to create or modify
landscape components itself.
So there's a few options here.
We've got the new tab or the new button here, which allows you to create a new material,
a new landscape completely.
Import allows you to create a new landscape based on a height map texture that you will
import, which we're going to take a look at later on.
Let's go take a look at the meat and potatoes of this section here, which is these tools
over here, like select, add, delete and splines really.
So select allows me to select a few components and then I can go on the details panel to
actually edit them.
You can see everything's grayed out here.
And the only reason for this is because I don't have my landscape actually selected
in the outline.
And so if I have the landscape selected, when I select those components, you can see now
I can actually edit them.
So select allows you to select and deselect if you, you know, re-click on a selected component.
And you can see we have a brush size here.
And if I bring this brush size up, you can see it allows you to select more components
at once.
So this is consistent across all of these tools.
So you should feel comfortable using it once you create a new or make a new selection or
add something.
And then we've got a little button here that's handy to just clear the selection so that
we don't have to individually deselect the sections that we want.
Add allows us to add a landscape component.
So for example, I can just click and drag and add a new, an entire new row and delete
can allow us to do exactly the same, but just, well, exactly the opposite rather and delete
sections.
Now, move and resize, we're going to skip for this.
Move just to give you a quick overview.
We need kind of a level set up to look at this, but it gives you the ability to move
certain components to different streaming levels so they can be streamed in and out
independently from the rest of the landscape, which is a nice sort of performance optimization
that you could use.
Resize allows you to resize the landscape.
And then the splines tool is the one I wanted to take a look at because this one's actually
quite powerful.
It allows you to edit the landscape based on splines that you can draw.
So say for example, I press control click to add a new spline point.
I can press control click again to add a few spline points.
And with these, I can also rotate them to change the tangents and say, for example,
I would raise this point here and maybe lower this point a little bit.
Once I click deform landscape to splines, and in this case, I'll just click all splines
because we only have one, but you can see it will actually deform the landscape to the
spline that I created, which is a really handy tool.
And one other thing that I quite like about it is that it's additive.
So once you've selected that, you could actually move this over and then add to that landscape
that you created.
So really neat little tool to actually just get some basic shapes and information layout
just with some easy splines.
Now when we take a look at managing and kind of like a real use case of how, you know,
why we'd want to select a particular landscape components, let's say for example, that this
is the playable space of the other player and that these landscape components, you know,
they have some, let's say, let's give it some mountains, you know, some really, really
basic mountains that I'm going to make here.
But let's say you just have some background information that you actually don't need to
be as detailed as the rest of your landscape.
Maybe you want to give them a particular material that's a little bit more performant and simpler.
So in order to actually edit that, what we'd want to do is select the sections that we
want to edit.
Say in this case for this mountain range, we'd select this last three rows of components
and go ahead and select them.
And what we'd want to do is essentially override the material.
So if I said override, I can go ahead and override a material, add a new element here.
And I'm just going to give this a new lot index of one.
And I can now add, for example, a material that's a little bit more performant and simpler
than what we have.
So I'm just going to use a background material.
And now what we have is a landscape component that's using a different material to the rest
of the landscape.
And as I say, this can be really handy to essentially relieve some of the complexity
of the landscape in areas that the player doesn't really need to access or don't need
high detail.
And the cool thing about this is that you can set up as many LOD indexes as you need
and you can actually sort of ramp that detail intensity away from the player or the playable
space.
So that's a really sort of real world case scenario of how you'd use the manage tool
to edit the landscape components themselves.
So with that being said, I think we'll go ahead and take a look at creating landscapes
and how we can create a landscape from height maps and different landscape creation modes
that we can use.